[Music]
so hi everyone I'm passenger I'm one of
the organizers of node BOTS
I have chato and a who also organizing
node BOTS so this is fourth time we
organized node but at Java Script Asia
and so typically what we do is we start
with this what we call a simple bot so
it's it's two servos our dinner Nano and
just a breadboard and we just control it
and so this time what we did was we
started off from that and we try to make
I don't try add stuff to it or remove
stuff from it and just do something with
it so yeah the first one we have is the
so cameras
so everything in here actually run with
powered by JavaScript yes
so so this is how it was so when you so
when you so this is turning left and
right so there is orange color when you
turn left and right and front it's when
you go front it's red and back it's
green that's that's pretty much it in
the table be careful yeah
so it's by here Ash and his team is done
this one so no we let keep it in the
last one yeah
so if you have seen the Twitter feed
this called JavaScript Roomba
so you are cleaning but it's affirmation
yeah is the next version control them
from the command line from the mobile
phone Oh what do we have here so the one
you asked for this is a note cat it's
for people who might not have a cat but
missed one of the most important
features of a cat which is crawling
around a table and knocking stuff over
so that's exactly what it does it's
gonna search for stuff around it it has
like a pattern and once it's find
something hopefully it's not gonna do it
second try it uses a proximity sensor to
see that it has an obstacle then it
proceeds to ram it off the table
it's a ultrasonic sensor no I think I
pressed something do it do it yeah as
you can see it's mostly like a cat
pretty useless yeah it even stopped on
its own I'm proud of it
thank you I think the biggest challenge
in building this is that hardware never
works like you really wanted to or like
document it or in any sensible way
so you just figure out what you can work
with and just try to get your code to
work around those issues
[Applause]
okay so this what I have metrics
animation so my friends and I am star
building the website with reactor yes
yeah which can do animation and display
animation on this grid so and this is
the default button so you if you if I
hit this it's gonna display the light
here so I start doing my example which
is really hard to building this with my
friends yeah it's a Jess car yeah so am
I gonna hit deploy button we speed 100
milliseconds for keyframe okay but I
think it's broken now so but we have
backup I held it I can let let you let
you see in this video instead
okay here is this okay try to hit deploy
button yeah
as it works thank you there's something
happened between me traveling from our
workshop to the stage so yeah okay for
for mine this is called blue car because
it's used Bluetooth so unlike other car
like note cut so it doesn't need why not
cut it actually tail it's a feature
so I can move from afar so we also tried
to make something so so this is what we
tried to make so this is basically uh a
pump that is supposed to inflate the
balloon
he promised me explosions beforehand I
was like don't tell me I need a license
yeah you will have to say a whole day
here yeah so that's pretty much it for
that Wow awesome
that was impressive in that hard way is
hard I guess like he promised explosions
I'm almost I guess maybe tomorrow give
them all a round of applause it's like
two days of work thank you so much guys
[Applause]